[Laughter]
they're gonna be like what did you and
whitney do
to where you need kleenexes up your nose
hi guys
so we just finished our fist fight i won
clearly this is all my blood just it
used to be a white t-shirt
second nosebleed in my life and
whitney's beautiful home triggered it
triggered it
this is the first time we've actually
got to hang out one-on-one and i was
expecting such a
glamorous beautiful swan
i'm excited we're going to be doing a
beauty treatment
obviously this is perfect for me today
a full face of makeup as i apply a
face mask to my face um it took like uh
many tools to apply the layers of
shackle
shellac on my face it looks great though
it just makes me want to sneeze
if you can use blood everywhere oh my
god
they might i'll owe you a new towel but
i think it'll be okay okay do you need
to sneeze
uh i'll blur this out oh
oh it's fine we're good if it gets worse
we'll get you a
light flow tampon that won't be the only
place i have one right now so
i have a super i thought i was gonna be
the cross one in this video
i'm used to being the grass one the sad
thing is i don't even know what that
means
it's what everything you're doing you
are the embodiment
i like how i asked whitney for water
earlier and she brought me
flavored sparkling pellegrino
that's fancy and they know that fancy
right brought me wine
wait i brought her wine and then she
gave me a gift because she felt
obligated because i gave her a gift
and then she gave me another gift to one
of my gifts on top so you gave me a wine
opener and a candle
that i liked that smelled good and then
you started hemorrhaging from the face
yeah i was over my mind was blown
by the the line opener that she showed
me so what this was
sponsoring i'm really concerned about
this you i showed you generosity
and your mind exploded and you just
started bleeding i've been in la for too
long i know we need to get you some
nicer friends yeah
well now i know where you live yeah you
just follow the trail of blood yeah
i feel like we really are becoming
friends i think so i think you're um
me i thought you were gonna say mean and
i was like oh [ __ ]
i like i got tricked into a call-out
video no no no it's not live
it's on a camera i know it's your camera
you could tackle me
delete it from my camera i can't tackle
you you're covered in blood you're just
slippery piece of shoes
but we're the only ones here in the
middle of fields
i know but you gave me wine i couldn't
catch you
you got me all slowed her down liquored
her up
[Applause]
i'm too groggy strategy but i do feel
like i'm you a little bit if you're me
then i'm you
yeah i'm like you just less bloody yeah
which is great you're like the better me
than
what you're saying the bloodless you
know oh we even have the same top bun
you do how cute are we yours is smoother
you're like the better version of me
you're like um
we're like the before and after mug shot
okay now we're being nice
this is like this is the mug shot for
shoplifting
and this is the mug shot for getting
caught shoplifting
the viewer is now fully the third wheel
yeah on a first date
oh not going to do well at all
everybody's going to hate it and never
want to sing
okay let's get some thumbs up all right
masks cleanse face and dry face before
using
done people get called out for that i
know
people get called out for lying and
saying they're not wearing makeup yeah
but we actually
aren't i am wearing a full face of
literal shoe can i use your nose blood
just have me over here and bottle my
blood and then sell it as your new
makeup line i feel like that would be a
hit brain
you know i get a lot of compliments from
lawyers actually and they're like oh you
should be a lawyer
so maybe really i think they're flirting
with you
our elbows are now touching
i don't know who's going to move the
elbows i'm fine with it this is like a
game of chicken then i'll play all day
long i'm pretending to read this
act like we're starting but whitney
hasn't let me um
whoever moves their elbow first is is
pulling away from this relationship yeah
and you're the reason why it didn't work
out whoever pulls away is the uh
by the way whitney canceled on me like
this is
a call-out video how many times have you
canceled
me we've rescheduled a couple of times
don't move your elbow
i like how she um i like how she
rephrased
the cancer called rescheduling okay and
i completely understand we're
schedulings
but i get it and i just wanted to say
when you did that to me
when did you go through our text message
this did go on for truly six months
but i stood strong i was like all right
tell me when
you have been what time you have what's
your address
you have been in florida this is true
for a while
to be fair but pre-florida uh sorry half
this conversation is us talking about
our ovaries
my ovaries to be exact i've been
bleeding from everywhere
for those of you that are curious amanda
loves the voice memo
she loves the voice and they put a lot
of effort into them
it's not my first take three voice memos
in a row not i'm gonna wait for your
response just gonna record it
i'm just gonna get ahead of it i already
know what you're gonna say i need to
work out my patience yeah that shows you
didn't even listen to this
okay okay this is a reschedule this is
annoying i'm shooting this thing for
spotify they're now moving it to the
afternoon i see
i said i swear i'm not this much of a
flake
she realized it because i realized it
yeah
and then she wrote back damn it whitney
i'm the worst that's probably
the sixth time but then she said i'll be
in florida
so then she was in florida that was me
telling her you missed your chance here
girl
i'm in florida now this has been going
on for a while
also another thing about amanda that you
guys should know she puts
a space at the end of her sentences
before
punctuation the punctuation
i'm not a spanish keyboard that's a
psychopath
i all blame autocorrect i hope
everything is okay
space exclamation mark exclamation mark
look at this oh why do i do that
space period oh i do it there too i know
november 15th of last year
a picture of the mask i think i'm going
to edit this video down
and then just keep rescheduling it yeah
cleanse and dry face before using
nailed it done uh
wow okay let me get you in the gym maybe
do some traps
expect intense tightening sensations
should i put this on my vagina
life hack if applied close to under eye
area you may experience gradual pulling
effects
don't be alarmed don't be alarmed push
it upwards to lift
cap how old is this
it's kind of it's crusted over
here there's a plume of dust don't make
your
teeth no okay it's done then
no we do that you know what i mean got
it just i don't know how to explain what
i just did it's like peeling all the
metal off mine did you want me to do it
yeah
oh i didn't expect you to take me up on
that are you mad at me are you type a
very me too yeah yeah i can tell
by how well you organize your resentment
towards me yeah
if you know i'm type a and you
reschedule on me i know
if there wasn't a pandemic it would have
been a little different
yeah you're going to use covet as your
ex i have like a good six
months okay
okay there's my empathy yeah i would say
that was a robot
there's my empathy there was my empathy
for you
excuse me okay we both have these out
now
see i actually am type a i really do
want to get this right
you're a robot you know you're not a
robot you're like um
you know those balloons in front of car
dealerships that start loading and then
they go up and they're
moving around just let me know if my
nose is well you have to pop this on oh
i thought you meant that one if her nose
starts bleeding i'm not gonna tell her
i'm on your guy's
side i'm gonna let it bleed and it's
gonna be amazing i promise not to tell
her they've never seen my nosebleed
you're welcome lubricant for all
of that noise
it's been a while for whitney guys who
says lubricant do you mean
lube like it's just i'm a robot
dude i was gonna say the robot glitched
you guys that's how
real people talk i'm not a beauty
influencer
oh thank you it's fine your blood is all
over my core
it's honestly the least gross thing that
has come out of your body in my house
okay but you know
at this you are so typical eight
nine you're ten seconds behind me i know
that's a good thing we put a towel here
well thought out on your end i'll give
you that
thank you i appreciate that we have the
same table
and the same dress i feel like we're we
do
but i feel like i should paint yours
with yours because i feel like yours is
better
yeah you know what i mean that was not
how you were supposed to be
minimize facial movements to maximum
challenge you're a robot this will be
easy for you swivel get that swivel on
oh my gosh
you are oh if you
avoiding the chair well it's fine it'll
loose cover up the blood from your nose
it's great makeup remover as well isn't
it
it's all coming off
it's good it's staying on but it's
foaming
do am i do i look like i'm
[Applause]
what do i look like does it look crazy
let's just do it with your face i do not
want to if this
i would rather take one for the team i
posted a photo with um
makeup before and people were shocked so
it's fine what happened
you should wear makeup more often no
they didn't
no it's fine it's the internet it
happens yeah that's just flirting
it's good she catches it with her boobs
i do but the thing is it landed on your
towel and then you put your
boobs on top i'm just trying to i'm just
trying to make oh
entice your audience over
after we met i followed you
which is a big thing for me yeah didn't
even mute you
normally i follow you i did shave my
mustache today that's good i didn't
i think we would have been better off
taking it
why are you having this oh my god i got
it
why are you looking at me hysterically
laughing i don't know what i look like
[Applause]
like um like a stalagtite or a
stalagmite
do i just look like a sad beehive right
hurry up because okay it's going in my
mouth yeah
okay hurry up do your fans know how
tight there you are
i don't think so yeah it's a little like
it looks a little like
curdled yeah like cottage cheese that's
right it does look like um
a load of cottage cheese load this
actually looks good on you
it doesn't look as crazy as it seems to
have on me
i do think this is expired
i don't think it's supposed to have
these little chunks in it
all right i feel like that's my nose i
didn't i want your nose to age faster
than the rest of your face
it looks too young sabotaging me i don't
know how you're from florida and you
have such good skin i don't go in the
sun i'm
super white now they make them starting
to have a chemical reaction
you know what i like about us we're
resourceful yes
and we're very honest with each other
right away and uh
moving forward you're not allowed to
have other girlfriends
i get it my love is so all-consuming
that you won't really need other friends
that's good though yeah i don't like a
ton a ton a ton of friends yeah no
you won't have any after this there's no
like resentment yeah
i mean you can call each other out on
things are you
talking about and i feel like it's a job
about me
no no it wasn't no it wasn't
no really if i was getting if i jab at
you you'll know
i'll feel it i'm trying to win this
right i'm trying to win the that's this
video
i'm trying to wait okay we can't smile
okay
how do the housewives do it aren't they
supposed to fill them up
let's see it's getting crackly
you starting to feel it tightening i'm
just going to move a little bit to make
it less chunky to
look like i've had such high
expectations for this
i know this is bad i feel like it's
gonna it said 30 minutes so
okay it's just i don't think it's
supposed to have chunks
i think we need to write a yelp review
hey guys you need to make your product
work for people that reschedule for
eight months
how long did you just shoot it
what did you just ask me like how much
footage do you have like it's like
an hour have you told everyone how you
like taught yourself how to do all this
stuff
probably on like other people's stuff
but not on my stuff
your fans don't even know how you did
started this no
they might if they seen the different
interviews and stuff but
i am so i'm not a sincere moment that
you're probably going to edit out and
that's fine send it to me from my
channels
uh i am so impressed you use these no i
didn't cut it off
does this bother you i just okay you're
starting to look old
it looks like what my makeup looks like
every day here in los angeles
my freckles are way more prominent than
your freckles but i like them i think
they're sexy
thanks these little ones are cute yeah i
have a ton that's cancer
this is getting tighter and tighter this
is really starting to constrict my
facial movement this one freckle right
here
and then it came it came out of nowhere
hr
yeah oh my god now i can't move my shoes
yeah i know what it is this is okay yeah
no this is what's supposed to do
where's the mall it's like right here
where my sweat is right
she is by the way she's very sweaty
she's a swampy lady
a lot of people don't know that about
certain areas you're really
jesus christ this is the temperature
whitney keeps her health
no it's the air i do think the air is
completely
you almost messed up my mask oh i've now
it's messed up
it was so perfect before yeah it makes
it feel like you're
um snatched what's that mean
like a snatch your wig like a snatched
waist a snatched
face a snatched i don't know i heard
somebody else say it
yolo no
cool beans i like that is that back
i don't think i ever left really yeah i
think it did
divorced men with pocket protectors for
a while cool beans
yeah if i was on a date with a guy and
he said cool means
i would be like uh it'd be a bummer yeah
be a good name for a vegan restaurant
cold beans it's funny how like depends
on what it's for you know what about uh
i would go to cool
fears is that still happening yeah
fierce you hear that on netflix all the
time johanna sometimes says like
my boys is english his first language
no that's why that's a very european
thing oh is that though yeah it's like
my
boys i love my blues
yeah yeah this is why youtubers get
cancelled i just realized
i'm in comedy so it's like slightly
different oh
that's good yeah how was that how was
that
the worst interviewer ever
just the whole thing yeah
comedy when you transcribe something or
you know take a clip out of context when
you're not watching the whole clip or
you don't know the person's previous
work or you know you just see
something completely out of context it's
probably easy to
pathologize it or just anything out of
context not even comedy it's just like
take something out of this clip and he
said you know nothing about this person
you haven't seen any of their specials
you haven't look at all their tweets
this is what they do
you know and um i feel like i'm frowning
at you but
i know why are you mad are we gonna
fight
you're a different person yeah oh my god
it looks
so crazy my lips are like i know you do
look like um
i just got like a different model yeah
oh
my god this mine is different mine's
pulling my lip up
that's what i feel like it's doing your
mind a little yeah it is you're like my
lips look fuller yeah i kind of look
i kind of you look like selena gomez
i get that
your eyes look awesome oh my god it's so
i look sad
you look five
this like subscribe where did you find
this who told you
i'm hip okay i just hope i have my
okay after that here's my finger on the
pulse and if nothing else comes from
this video
i am going to auction off amanda's uh
nose blood
like enough i know i'm going to put
these on ebay
and that looks like nothing i guess it's
better that it looks like nothing
where's the really bloody one did you
throw your trash let's get it
this is what i came for this is what
you're gonna look like when you're old
we now know
you're still gonna be honest i don't
think this is true
all right okay this feels very tight i'm
gonna miss my lips
and when i watch this off i will look
like dakota fan
really that's i better
[Music]
we have the same sinks do we yeah i feel
like we are
weirdly similar you were really nice to
me
yeah what goes on yeah what happens
no i mean like you know it's how some
girls like
a little bit of a diva or whatever and
it's a set you're on
often you know yeah i think for me like
i've been on the receiving end of a lot
of that and i never want to repeat
that feeling towards for other people to
have and sometimes you do it by accident
just because you're insecure
or you're scared or whatever
women are so pitted against each other
naturally i just try to go out of my way
to be like
we're not doing that yeah you know a
guard or
something that's up yeah oh my god i
have blue eyeliner all over
yeah but i think um i feel like i'm
carving like a clay
sculpture but yeah you were nice
so there's that well
that's all it takes now but also you
have such a like
warm energy i feel grateful that it's
off me too yeah that was fun
worth the eight month wait yeah